try and pay play with a lot of pace and
space here's cunningham on the wing
alien now shot clock down to 12. killian
into the corner cunningham with his
first shot is good
cunningham got hit with the screen
couldn't get around and they get the
miss anyway
cunningham is second three ball on the
wave got it boy
he is aggressive he didn't step on
anybody's foot which usually can lend
itself to
a more severe injury he just twisted it
and cunningham
with a little bit of anticipation
defensively
punches one home building and not just
building but winning as well
cunningham had a shot blocked got it
back
inside the three-point line and switches
you see some of the quickness oh man
yeah three for ten
and cunningham with another bucket
green felt the contact gets it to go and
won this is what he learned in the g
league watch this
he's gonna keep the defender on his back
see that the defender can never
as far as international kids outlet pass
to jalen green
finds that three-point line knocks down
his first three with a houston rocket
let's see if he can get to the basket
shot clock is off
game clock is down to six jalen greene
with hands on his hip gets the bucket
[Applause]
and that'll do it for the first quarter
the number two overall
pick slithering through the defense so
smooth that young man played for mick
cronin at cincinnati
and that was not his forte jaylen green
with a step back three
want to watch his play-making
play-making ability
we know he can score what does he do in
pick-and-roll
[Music]
cut off by stevens but he's still fine
when you play against the defenses in
the nba an 18-5
houston run dating back to the second
quarter
jalen green curling off the screen
knocks down watch this now
with against an elite defender
[Applause]
mobley get touches and that's what he's
doing six point lead for houston jalen
green
dancing with the ball up against stevens
another step back
that is his signature move already
jaylen green
thinks he's the best player out here
that's that's
perfect footwork right there jalen hans
who has always had that speed
you know green's going right back to the
bucket he's gonna get
finished for two he's got 23 points
already
as he physically physically figures
everything out
evan mobile now
yep and that's the pick and roll iq i
wanted to see from
jalen green